diese tat wird nie zu verstehen sein und
trotzdem suchen wir nach erklärungen und
das tun wir hier im studio mit dem
profiler marke hoffmann ihnen einen
guten abend
wir haben ein paar informationen
mittlerweile über diesen offenbar
psychisch kranken mann zunächst
vielleicht die frage warum immer wieder
männer so war es bei breivik in oslo bei
steinhäuser ein junger mann ein
jugendlicher aber männlich damals in
erfurt amokläufe ist das typisch
männlich es ist typisch männlich aber
trotzdem liegt darin natürlich nicht die
ursache und tatsächlich ist diese
ursache bis heute noch nicht genau
geklärt es gibt viele wenn man in die
kriminalstatistik schaut gibt es viele
wenn ich sogar die meisten oder die
große mehrheit der gewaltdelikte bei den
männern vollkommen klar dominieren es
ist aber nicht klar warum das so ist
manchmal wird testosteron als erklärung
genommen dass das zu mehr aggression
führt da bin ich etwas skeptisch denn
auch da kann es manchmal sein dass man
ursache und wirkung verwechselt man hat
nämlich festgestellt dass wenn man
personen beispielsweise auch an
testosteron ist auch etwas was in der
situation entsteht und manchmal ist es
eher die wirkung und nicht unbedingt die
ursache aber die frage ist auch in der
kriminologie noch nicht ganz geklärt
aber ich glaube das profil eines
amoktäters dazu kann man schon etwas
sagen und da gibt es mehr als nur den
faktor dass die männlich sind also der
typische amoktat also wenn man so will
der typische amoktäter fernab von diesem
fall obwohl wir gleich schauen können
was in diesem fall auch zu treffen was
man ohne spekulationen sagen kann
beispielsweise alter und geschlecht das
sind der dinge die von der polizei
bereits bestätigt sind das typische
motiv das motiv und das profil sind zwei
verschiedene dinge aber ich glaube um
den typischen amoktäter zu verstehen
muss man sowohl das motiv verstehen als
auch das profil des motives
typischerweise eine tiefsitzende
kränkung oder viele kränkungen die sich
über viele jahre angesammelt haben
professor doktor rainer schaller betonte
immer wieder die macht der kränkung die
vielen psychischen erkrankungen zugrunde
liegt man sagt ja auch so
umgangssprachlich was krank macht krank
es ist aber auch die ursache für viele
verbrechen wenn nicht sogar die mehrheit
der gewaltverbrechen auch
beziehungsdelikt und ganz andere taten
definitiv und ohne zweifel aber die
hauptursache für terroristische
einzeltäter und
professor haller spricht in dem
zusammenhang auch von kränkung delikt
was eigentlich ein ganz gutes wort ist
um das in einem wort zu beschreiben sie
sind gekränkt ein deutscher amokläufer
hat mal als ursache für seine tat
angegeben dass er vor sieben oder zehn
jahren auf einer klassenfahrt nach rom
wollte niemand mit ihm auf ein zimmer
diese kleinen momente können aber tiefe
narben auf der seele hinterlassen das
sind im grunde momente die den
selbstwert einer person die unseren
selbstwert angreifen
nun ist aber trotzdem der punkt warum
richtet sich die personen nicht selbst
das wäre ja ein motiv sich vielleicht
selbst das leben zu nehmen
warum attackiert jemand anderes das ist
ja noch mal eine ganz andere schiene
im grunde kann man das in einem satz so
zusammenfassen wenn ich nicht glücklich
bin sollte es auch nicht sein das heißt
bei amok täter sieht man eine
tiefgreifende wut gegen die glückliche
gesellschaft das heißt die personen die
angegriffen werden wahllos sind im
grunde ein symbol nämlich das steht für
die glücklichen leute die das glück
haben was der proteste ein oder andere
facebook posts vielleicht schließen den
wir auch in dem
kurzen film gesehen haben gegen frauen
aber auch die politik gegen viele andere
teile der gesellschaft absolut und das
ist immer ganz beliebt dass man die
schuld auch für das eigene versagen oder
die eigenen fehler immer gerne bei
anderen sucht aber es gibt noch weitere
dinge die man zum typischen profil sagen
kann typischerweise sind täter jungen
sind frustriert sie sind gekränkt sie
haben außerdem noch kürzliche
rückschläge die dazu kommen zu
kränkungen die möglicherweise sieben
jahre her sind oder noch länger
sie sind häufig psychosoziale isoliert
das heißt kein fester freundeskreis
oftmals keine partnerin oftmals auch
keine feste arbeit arbeitslos das heißt
es fehlt irgendwie das soziale umfeld es
gibt weder weder den kegelclub noch den
freundeskreis noch die arbeit es gibt
irgendwie nichts was auf fängt das noch
oft gepaart mit narzisstischen
persönlichkeit zügen anderen psychischen
erkrankungen und bei zwei drittel der
amok fälle spielt alkohol eine rolle
entweder direkt bei der begehung der tat
oder im kontext davor und ganz wichtig
zu betonen ist mir aber das ist die
kombination dieser dinge ist einzeln ist
es nicht stark und jeder versuch ein
einzelnes merkmal der liste zur
alleinigen ursache zu erklären ist
einfach sachlich falsch wenn leute sagen
männer sind das problem ja auch wenn
fast alle amokläufer oder täter männer
sind sind natürlich nicht alle männer
amok-täter auch personen die sagen
alkohol das ist der grund er war
betrunken alkohol ist teufelszeug nun
1,4 promille hatten wir alle
möglicherweise schon mal ohne eine
solche tat begangen zu haben
besonders gefährlich sind die zwei
kombinationen frustration bzw kränkung
und psycho soziale isolierung denn wenn
sie gekränkt sind und freunde haben dann
werden sie möglicherweise aufgefangen
von familie oder freunden wenn sie
gekränkt sind und allein dann fängt es
an gefährlichen werden wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren